III is fast approaching and will soon
learn about all the hot new games we get
to play over the next year or so but if
you're an Xbox Live Gold member and want
to know what you can play in June for
free I've got you covered and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button to
be the first to know about the games
with gold lineup every month
first up for the Xbox one is
speedrunners a side-scrolling racing
game that started out on a 360 as speed
runners HD now you can get your hands on
the Xbox one debut all month long
speedrunners is available june 1st
through the 30th also available all
month long is the phantom dust
multiplayer dlc this is a bit of a weird
one since phantom dust just got a
re-release itself it's not a remake or a
remaster but it is free for anyone to
download and now you'll be able to check
out some extra multiplayer content free
of charge to finally watchdogs will be
available from june 16th through July
15th so if you haven't checked out the
gritty faux techno future of Chicago yet
you've got a few extra weeks to dig in
on the 360 side you can grab some hidden
blades and go stabbing Patriots and
Assassin's Creed 3 Connor Davenport
doesn't get quite as much love as fan
favorite Ezio but you can give his
adventure a go by picking it up for free
from June 1st through the 15th then on
the 16th you can get medieval with
Dragon Age Origins the RPG that started
a whole new Bioware phenomenon if you're
ready to battle the darkspawn you can
set out from June 16th through the 30th
and don't forget that both of these
games can also be played on Xbox one
thanks to backwards compatibility and
those are your free games with gold for
June 2017 you can always check out
plenty of gameplay and reviews for these
titles over at GameSpot and if you want
to know what free games are still
available for May you can check out that
video too
you